hi Samuel leaves here and in this video
I wanted to explain how you can get
direct deals from estate agents
particularly I'm talking about lease
option agreements rent to rent no money
down deals if that's you stay tuned so
on our Facebook group I just get people
asking me all the time they've never
attended the crash course they've never
attended any training but they keep
asking me how do you get deals from
estate agents how do you get them to
understand rent two rents how do you get
them to understand Lease Option
agreements I've spoken to ten agents and
I've been rejected by them all what do
we do what do we do and the problem is
is their strategy is wrong because if
you try and get a lease option agreement
from an estate agent it's just not going
to happen unless you're extremely good
at communicating yourself and you've got
dogged resistance and determination and
can keep going and don't mind being told
no and getting rejected time and time
again you're really going to struggle
doing that it's just a bad strategy
because let me tell you what's a bad
strategy I used to be an estate agent
and estate agents they're not property
experts they're just salespeople that
happen to sell property and they sell
property in a particular way and when
you come along someone that they don't
know they don't like going trust
just someone comes along and says I'm
looking to buy property oh but I don't
want to do it your way I want to do it
like this it's called renter and it's
called lease option agreement you're
just gonna annoy them it's gonna confuse
them irritate them and then it's not
gonna want to know so let me explain
what to do instead instead of trying to
get deals from direct from agents what I
do what I did and as I say I used to be
in a state agent I did it for three
months just to gain experience and to
make friends I know it's sad but best
best investment is yourself so what you
want to do is you want to find
properties that are you know lend
themselves well to be a read to rent or
a lease option agreement and we cover
all this stuff on training so if you
haven't come to the crash gloss by the
way you should don't even bother just
stop watching this video and go and book
on to the property investors crash
course we go through all this in great
detail but what you want to do is you
want
find a good property that lends itself
well to a normally done deal rather than
going to the agent and saying this is
what we're looking for find the deals
and then go direct to vendor so you cut
the estate agent out now we go through
how to do that at the crash course you
might think that's unethical you might
think but if we cut the estate agent out
then they're gonna lose their fee and
let's get anything they're gonna be
bothered about losing their say but what
you're gonna do is you're gonna cut them
out and go direct to the vendor and if
the deal comes off and you're succeed
the dude doesn't come off you've not
lost
you've not cost or lost the agent
anything the deal is the deal comes off
only there is the stage you're gonna be
out of pocket so you're going to rip to
vendors if the deal comes off you've got
a house we've no money for free
congratulations you did it a proportion
of that you should then go back to the
agent and offer to pay the agents fee
and just say look agent I'm really sorry
I bought I bought this property which
was on with you and to be honest if you
hadn't have marketed it I probably
wouldn't have known it existed and and
because of me it's now off the market
and I feel quite bad would there be any
way I could pay your fee to compensate
what's happened now think about this not
only is that ethical number one but also
number two it works and you're going to
get more deals but also number three
this is the icing on the cake when you
do it that way it's ethical it works but
also the estate agent is going to be
thinking well I didn't do anything in
this and the house is now off the market
and we've been paid and haven't done
anything hmm it suddenly flips the cards
and then the estate agent will become
your best deal sourcing machine and they
will work for free as long as they get
their fees paid which is nothing in the
grand scheme of things that's how some
of my students after they've gone on the
training are getting himself two three
four five property deals without
spending any money by doing it on a
lease option agreement or regiment or
whatever they're doing it because
they're working with the stages this way
that's the smart way that's the right
way around
so hope you found that helpful so please
stop forming out with a state agent stop
your getting rejected over and over you
don't need to do that so you can either
be the kind of person that just does it
your way and gets rejected rejected
rejected rejected you might get there in
the end but you can have so many scars
and stab wounds from all the rejection
and the hardships and the crawling over
the glass or you can just learn to do it
the right way make money get financially
free and do it ethically and don't upset
anybody I would choose the latter hope
to see you in training god bless you
have a great week thank you so much for
watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time